all right cherry's off today so your
most accurate weather now forecast
starts with another flag blowing in the
wind but
i think it's fair to call this kind of a
brief break because it was
super windy over the weekend gusts over
30 miles an hour in many neighborhoods
we're in the 15 to 20 mile an hour range
hanging on to 51 degrees out at mccarran
but what's happening in your
neighborhood we got the warm spot along
the strip at 52
but many neighborhoods you guys are
waking up to the 40s and even those
breezes
to 15 20 miles an hour make that feel
like the lower 40s so you're going to
want to think about a sweater or a
jacket
especially getting the kids off to
school have the school bus stop forecast
here in an hour or so
seven hills and anthem you guys are at
47. let's move on to nevada and beyond
including the mid 60s for death valley
but ely jumps out in the teens right now
and there's a much better chance for
some snow flurries
overnight tonight and during the day
tomorrow as another round of wind gets
ready to whip on through prop you're at
46 right now
you're matching that in sandy valley so
we'll go for
68 today it should feel a little bit
better with a little less wind
sun of course not getting up until 6 41
going to bed at 6
54. there's the normal high of 72.
so there is another storm system that's
already pounding the pacific northwest
and marching
right into our backyard will include a
really slight chance for some passing
sprinkles mostly cloudy overnight
and then it's that wind that will start
whipping so
just as has been the case with the past
several weather systems that once they
gone from us it turns into big time snow
in denver
and rain in the midwest here's your
eight day forecast after
68 today windy and 62 tomorrow we'll
start bouncing back up on the
temperature roller coaster
breezes will continue off and on we'll
look for readings overnight in the upper
40s
daytime highs actually could start
climbing close to 80 again by the time
we get to next week john alex